hello and welcome to this video playing
Graz 15 let's play the petrov once again
now this is super popular really they
all play that and it's understandable I
do recommend this line myself
it gives wise and easy to play game and
you have chances for slight advantages
yeah damn okay
hmmm I did not intend to take on f3m but
it's difficult now to not do that bishop
h5 g4 is this awkward may not help him
not happy with this yeah that I played
really badly really not good
what has the bishop pair for absolutely
nothing
oh that's unless do it wait
[Music]
so I take you will take with the Queen
yeah uh-huh okay
mm yeah I'm taking with the Queen and
then I'm completely completely destroyed
I was more concerned about night g3
actually it's instead of taking what is
Queen f4 I don't get this move I can do
this here right g5 is not working I can
sacrifice why doesn't that work hmm
seems to be okay
tweener fighters g6
could have taken f4 actually Wow why
didn't I do that I was actually quite
quite a simple way to get a good
position hmm weird okay so g4 what's
what's going on let's do this
prepare who create and have a look at
the f4 square yeah I fended off any
immediate danger and I think the
position should be fine
anybody I'm a little bit quicker on that
file
really
okay um so I cannot go now therefore
that's clear but still this looks like
quite a weakening move where do we put
this maybe here
496
something that queen is queen III is
probably still equal
[Music]
I don't want to trade
I can go Queenie five black Queen f3
okay yeah now I'm getting somewhere
quicker on the e-file f4 is weak
Knight can come to a four that looks
good yeah let's see where he goes
okay so clean edge 496 no this one
should be f1 no h5 to immediately attack
this
and now knight c6 maybe and then maybe
rook e1 happens no that's not too great
let's just wait hold
you know how does it cover all that all
that stuff now don't quite see how each
for queen g4 queen g3 just about just
about
that's annoying really that there is a a
Bishop h3 oh my god oh I have the check
ouch ouch I have the chick oh I'm such
an idiot
after the way this game played out to
get into this is really all absolutely
terrible I mean I was just out blame and
slowly come on that's crazy
it's so totally crazy I mean I'm just
have I just have to be a bit precise him
and he completely killed himself with
this g4 nonsense g4 is this is
absolutely terrible and how did I spoil
this that's really crazy
so yeah matter of the right move over
probably Queen f3 inch 5 I mean I must
win yeah why don't I when thinking King
evaders maybe too lame I don't know I
have to go edge forward to isolate that
pawn that's true there probably we
wouldn't a pawn yeah yeah the problem
was I didn't really realize that he's
got this this damage form of him but
that really saves him I mean it's that
saves of course I can still play that
for win but but not it's not winning and
have success of course suicidal
and also here I mean I can also just
play an OG five or so and I might earn
any better after move like g4 not to win
is really crazy a g-force like insane
it's an insanely bad move because it
makes absolutely zero sense
you just weaken yourself totally I mean
you just weaken everything and you have
no benefit at all on the dark squares
then nothing is great ready and even the
ending is this is terrible
of course you can just do this and go
here but I wanted to made of course now
I don't want it wanted an ending you
know that before that I mean here here I
was also quite worse but I'm 94 and
taking on f6 it's just there's just no
test at all I mean I'm just okay and of
course I can take on f4 which is an
improvement and easy improvement yeah
it's probably equal Bishop f1 is
probably equal now it's okay g4 I can
still not get over that after this move
I'm not winning yeah this is the
cleanest way to do it just make sure
that this is never going to be covered
and this is super simple now I can take
and and I just win this pawn you cannot
cover whatever something like this for
example
he's just unable to cover it and then
Knight wins easily against Bishop yeah I
was that was absolutely bad okay thanks
for watching